yo is abuzz prestigio again today with a
little heroin experience so let's just
hop onto we're going to be doing so
today we'll be doing some finishing up
of the pen area probably just finished
one panel to smother pins later and you
know do that see what I was like I want
to go on a moneyed adventure so many
years would like that and also just guys
just uh as a thing to say try getting
this out there to more people telling
your friends about it if your friends or
like YouTube videos I'm trying to just
get a little more known that would like
some more views I go when I first
started the hair of an experience I was
getting oh but no we gotta stop that Oh
doing plenty sau offenses on me okk you
guys you guys gonna stop hopping over
nope no more hopping over for you but uh
yeah just try and get it more out there
because I would like to have the series
have more views on it and it's a series
i enjoy and obviously you guys that are
watching it enjoy it since you keep
watching it but the views just it's been
less than a hope like last last video um
past two videos one video got a hundred
views in the time the most recent video
got 50 so it's going slower so just just
go like share to your friends if they're
under that tell them about it just
trying to get the word a little more
known about it and i would really
appreciate that if you guys ever do that
and it'll bring a lot and also more
people like the more this but better
this series does the quicker i'll come
out with new new episodes so that's a
incentive to go get your friends to talk
about it as long as this is this is
getting these amounts of views i will
still post it pretty regularly pretty
regularly
and yeah Buddhist just something to say
so everything in here let's organizes a
bit all right makes a little more please
on the I throw rest of this stuff and
yes I can't want to go on a mind
adventure so we should do that for sure
I of keep inventory untrue [ __ ] I my not
so let's just not die it's a good plan
leather I think I guess one letter in
here yeah poop and lets uh music wise
music off want some music would that's
good ladders we do not any letters or
just the letters in there there should
be enough wood and torches we do not
have any arrows so Flint's feathers and
wood up nope huh puh-puh-puh buh-buh-buh
it's enough boom boom boom voilà that's
good get my arrows feather chin to get
thrown back into their let's let's
organize everything so organized this is
pretty organized will keep like that we
go organization organization like it's
only bone so no poo poo poos we have a
mistake and let's go and I time is a
good time to go down to the mines so
we're kind of gonna see if we can find
any new ones actually actually if i want
to find new minds like to go on a new
adventure and let's run this i just
really make this a mind car or something
someone is just that if he a while ago
so if i'm actually i'm going to do that
then let's sleep 222222 sleepy sleepy
all right let's go
and Boop Oh nope nope nope nope nope
what oh gosh within a tree Wow weird
place to be in a tree like halfway up it
well good thing I use my axe to get out
okay you have something definitely gotta
watch yourself using this hair burn
until to roll into the bad stuff also
they did up the end of the urban mod so
next up so we should have like a
opponent of harappan you go you should
be alright this seems like a good spot
let's just make a little signet
signifying come on signifying thing up
boop boop boo I need to make it more
yeah I'm going to like a little more for
more should be good torch and torch
torch Oh to torch a torch that lets get
hard to TV down I'm let us go hopefully
he'll we'll head out some sort of mine
system you got this efficiency pic so
that'll definitely help help everything
go faster also he's meaning to ask you
guys I'm kind of at a loss for ideas for
videos since I my urban series I tried
to in a mod showcase recently and it's
not going too well like in terms of
reception like using stuff so I'm really
not sure in terms of minecraft what do
you guys want me to post I'll continue
posting this series since the people
that do watch this thing to really like
is the comments because like this is
mazen which I'm glad other you guys
enjoy it let's get the cobblestone right
here and torch I'm glad you guys enjoy
it that's actually I'm glad you enjoy it
and I'll keep doing it as long as people
keep enjoying it and it gets a good
amount of views but I just want to know
like if you guys have any
their ideas of videos that I should do
for the future and also for any of you
guys if you are call of duty fans tell
me what I should do for that too and I
thought I'd pretty ideal when the new
dlc comes out all I'll be hitting that
up right now I'm kind of at a loss and
snow watchman's random gameplay videos
so we found ourselves a cavern legit and
yeah so go make sure if you like to call
duty watch not called YouTube videos I
just push it up one up today tomorrow
you guys seen this Oh what on ease if I
was going to say I'm I'm peaceful
because i thought i wasn't peaceful a
long peaceful one as we in the mod
review didn't want the annoying spiders
getting my way but yeah so if you have
any ideas for videos leaving the
comments the voice your opinion and
because i want to hear I want to see
what you guys want me to do since
whatever you guys want we'll get get the
best videos like you guys wanted to
watch it so hunts best receptive videos
more some more IM really i really don't
need any resources but i guess we can be
looking for a UH a dungeon dungeon or
mine shaft since I you can find like
horse armor in my chest go on horse
armor its new quest fine horse armor
that's that's my new quest whoa see top
ones that let me just check them through
settings right ok bring this is great
all right well let's go let's go whoo is
it deep girl I should have brought a
bucket of water with me I should have
done it once on way down a bit actually
what am i doing bro haha torch oh we got
some gold legit and torch it all up
those because when this coal because
never
too much Colbert it's from cold calls
amazing love cold to go gosh Cole yes it
is not a le the charcoal yeah a charcoal
now look Stern and cold the texture okay
I really don't like the new trucker look
but oh no no no no no Oh where'd I spawn
in what the heck yeah I don't like the
new texture for charcoal but I guess
some people do and it is good that it's
finally different than coal it's kind of
done those the same school for so long
to like it was the same as coal for the
entirety of the game from now let's eat
some bread get some health regen going
in here and boot blue lapis all everyone
else lapis and jump up we got some more
like this I'll got a lot more lapis off
get that all over 15 nice to this will
actually make climbing up things a lot
easier this little hair burn oh yeah
there we go I'm a phone text written
text on my phone are you know actually
all right now I'm going to let me place
a torch I'm going to make a crafting
table oh I do a bucket of water their
mind right I'm like little book you
ordered a little water guy do all right
here is ami pick you up hello mr. zombie
alright only lets torch no not only that
torch torch out of iron I do have a lot
of iron packet back at the homestead buh
buh buh buh i think i'm just gonna well
I don't want to like oh hello I don't
want i go i was gonna say i'm just gonna
keep going to our fine horse armor I
don't know where my house is so I don't
want to just go infinitely away I
surveying this ravine dude do want far
there's some redstone i got this green
there's nothing green it's like
reflecting on my screen so i was a low
overruled there's no I'm building which
she said like we're not in a great need
for diamond is a bit cool we're not any
great need for diamonds so it's not like
I'm gonna look like freak out too much
of a find out a little bit like all
awesome found diamonds but won't be too
special my lapis the officers are like a
it can be such a peaceful game 1 of this
thing is to not have to be super
peaceful so we will have it cleaning
urban will make it a little cray-cray
we're clear oh I'm sorry that was just
bad oh boo what's over here any dungeons
that's better wow wow rather than done
to it too much damage to me
those laps do to do to look to 20 s
allah oh my gosh on shred soon oh my god
I think I just hit like a double pocket
huh and then a single piece of iron yeah
legit oh no get somewhere on we get
smart this is tailing back in to the
other part of it oh boo boo boo creeper
let's rid the world of one more creepy
come on crepes crepes creeps nope okay
suck it suck it let's get this lot out
of here this is block off all this lava
all right nothing over here oh hello
there's a zombie oh god nope nope oh
dang it getting any get hit like any
lava nope and torch torch torch so I my
screen is really glarus is hard for me
to seize and like portion of everything
I just now in this like have enough full
hunger bar makes me happy let's get all
this good stuff let me get the auto
switch mod auto switch mode makes the
leg is caused by something faster so I
switched my item like pickaxe stuff or
anything like that oh well this is not a
mind spree we're looking for a dungeon
so we run past all this Lutz anything
over here let's cross this
okay can't see anything there we go um I
got some gold I'll pick that up it's
gold oh there goes my torch it's gold
bro he's got you all we gotta get the
gold the gold this like most valuable I
didn't think game duh i'm online new to
Minecraft being cold poop if you don't
know but you should know you should know
was that a slime I here or just Azam
bees footsteps sound like a slime is to
me they sound like slimes I said like
light over here hello zombie I should
get a job I whoa big lava place there's
spider-man spider-man Oh Anna zombie Oh
multiple zombies all three triple
zombies triple kill little twine nice
are zombies 2 2 2 2 2 20 ah you're
singing dungeons why have to have
endured odds looking forward on Jindo
Diddy looking forward and Jane do you
gender that have passed above me see any
nope look at all clear the dunge eons
mmm now genitals were you hot nuts I'll
check around here let me let me place
there we go I'll check around here
though nothing i'm going to call it and
go over the video huh huh huh Oh creep
up multiple creeper it's a craving party
nope nope nope yeah jump shot there we
go find out if it's crude but uh oh nope
nope nope nope yeah yeah nice nice I'm
not really seeing much all that is all
over okay well um more work it arges
well i'm going to call it a n for the
video next video will can turn continue
our search for the dungeon Oh many mobs
will continue our search for the dungeon
and hopefully if we find one will be
able to find our way back home all terms
that is a beautiful way down to video oh
gosh oh gosh I think I'll just edit
looking at a time it's okay ya go
awesome just uh oh yeah look so good
alright guys you've enjoyed this make
sure you leave the light great comment
or subscribe
she later peace up
Oh
you